[Music]
david's with us in atlanta hi david how
are you
hey dave thank you guys so much for
taking my call sure what's up
hey so um
i'm 34 years old um i'm married i have
five kids
and we're kind of in a little bit of a
tough spot right now okay so
last year we purchased a house it was
three hundred and twelve thousand we are
three hundred thousand on it right now
um and so
the
the issue is that we have a house right
now
that
is uh
we
we have a rental property
that is completely um it's completely
paid off
um
what's it worth like
that house right now it's going for
about 225. the rental would sell for
225.
yes sir okay
okay um
the issue is that right now
we're
we're in about 46 000 in credit card
debt
and
we're just
you know my wife and i were new to the
baby steps um and we're to a point where
you know like at work the ceiling burned
out you know all the money that would
that that would come in
would immediately leave you know and it
just kind of feels like we're leaving
like you know we're living paycheck to
paycheck because you are that's why it
feels that way yeah
yeah what's your income household
so
right now
last year was 85 000
um
the year before that we're around 95 92
000
okay so about nine do you think you'll
do this year
um
uh you know i would say a safe number
maybe like 75 to 80 000. okay
are you guys doing a budget i know you
said you're new to the steps are you
doing a monthly budget on paper
and tracking it
yeah so we actually just started working
on one um
so yes yes we are okay you're just
getting started with the budget it
sounds like
yes it's because we got to find out
where all this money's going i mean you
guys make a decent income and it sounds
like there's nothing at the end of the
month and so we've got to figure out
where these money leaks are
in the budget if this is going to eating
out if this is going towards online
shopping but we gotta batten down the
hatchets here and get rid of this 46
thousand dollars in debt we'll worry
about the mortgage later on in the baby
steps
right so
you know i think a lot of it was eating
out you know we were eating out just the
money was just evaporating um and so
what my wife was doing
was pretty much we were living off of
credit cards yeah and so
you know now
you know we find ourselves ourselves in
a situation we're scrambling around you
know we're trying to pay down
um you know the debts from smallest uh
you know largest we're doing an
instacart uber and it's just
well let me tell you let me tell you
what let me tell you what i think is
happening and i it seems pretty
looking at it from this side anyway
you're 34 years old you got five kids
you both work
y'all are running wide open all the time
your lives are unbelievably busy
it's very hectic and in the middle of
hectic
you do two things one is you become
disorganized which never is an efficient
use of money and two is you buy a lot of
things that are time saving things
eating out as a time saver
anything you can do to because you're
tired
you're exhausted you're frenetic you're
going crazy the kids are screaming
because you got little kids you haven't
got five teenagers
you're out your house is wild
yep and you know in the middle of all of
that
um you're just trying to survive
and and so you're not doing anything
where you're telling things what to do
you're reactive instead of proactive on
everything
yeah pretty much yeah so what's going to
happen is when you go through financial
peace university
and you learn to become proactive and
doing the budget is a step of being
proactive
when you put every dollar on paper you
and your wife put those kids to bed turn
off the stupid television book a night
where you say we're going to spend two
hours on this first budget because the
first budget's really hard
and you're going to put it in the every
dollar app so both of you can track it
and i'm going to give you a year
different to ramsey plus so you can go
through financial peace university and
run the every dollar premium version of
the budgeting app okay
now when you start making when when you
start making this money behave
you're getting ahead of it instead of
behind it
then when you're tired and you get ready
to buy something you have to look at the
budget and see if you have the money
right you're going to get a raise it's
going to feel like you got a raise when
you get on a budget
now so here's my question you know being
so
i'm 30 you know 34 years old yeah um we
have nothing in change i know absolutely
nothing interesting the only equity we
have is
well we so the house that we just
purchased that it's already gained some
equity about forty thousand dollars yeah
and then the house that's paid off we
have a you know another
225 on a conservative side
so
my question is would you guys sell that
property i'm not trying to fix the
symptom i'm trying to fix the problem
okay
this the the credit card debt is a
symptom
of you being out of control and
disorganized
well let me tell you i'm absolutely done
with that all right i don't cut up all
my credit cards like there's no way in
the world i'm going back so what i would
tell you to do is let's get on this
budget and you two get in this class and
the two of you
get a calm
money rhythm as a couple
where you're behaving for about 60 to 90
days before you make a real estate
decision
okay let's start beating on these credit
cards using the debt snowball to begin
to pay them down
you're not going to make a huge progress
but about 90 days from now i'm going to
sell the rental
but i don't want you do it right now
because right now you're scrambling
trying to find a way to fix this and i
don't want you to fix this because this
is you
right we got to fix you we got to get
you guys in a rhythm and get you guys in
a behavior
the rental property then can use to be
used to clean up the credit cards when
we know they're not going to grow back
because now we're on a new system we
have a new way of doing things a new
life when it comes to money a new set of
principles that we operate by
more than it's just i'm done with this
and done with us is a good place to
start
but that's not a principle that will
drive you for 10 years
okay so then you sell the rental then
you pay off the credit cards then we pay
off your mortgage
yeah okay so you're saying go through
financial peace university then decide
if we're going to go ahead and sell the
rental property yes i think you are
going to sell it but i wouldn't until
you've done this because you're going to
be selling it for a different
emotional reason than you are today
you've been flailing around so long that
right now
selling the rental property is flailing
but when it's purposeful and intentional
and as a part of an overall strategy 90
days from now it's a whole different way
to sell it in a whole different place in
your psyche that you're sitting when
you're making that decision you're a
smart guy david
uh you just got you just got a lot of
irons in the fire yeah i mean you're
juggling flaming swords dude what we're
saying is we want to see behavior change
so that you have long lasting financial
success and right now selling is just a
shortcut and you could be back in the
same rhythms that you were beforehand
and so most people doing this plan david
they'll be out of debt in 18 to 24
months and you guys absolutely can do
that just based on the numbers without
even selling this rental property and so
that's what i want to see is some
gazelle intensity and obviously you got
five kids man your life is crazy but we
got to find some margin shape some
expenses bring in some more income and
get creative and get this thing out of
your life and never look back yeah and
then the burnout will start to go away
because you're burnt out because you're
you're a rat in the wheel
you don't feel traction once you start
seeing some traction from your work the
work takes on more meaning
and but you have to say have a sense of
we're going somewhere with this not like
we're just spinning out yeah and uh
that's where you're headed dude you're
gonna do fine six months from now if
you'll do the stuff we're teaching you
your life is gonna be completely
different your attitude your heart rate
when you're talking about this is going
to change the tightness across the top
of your shoulders is going to release
all of this is going to happen that's
why we call it financial peace
two words that don't go together like
fouchy math
and so you know check it out
ramsey
ramseysolutions.com
and you can plug into financial peace
university we're going to plug you in
though you hold on and we're going to
sign you up for a year's worth and get
you going